everyone i'm denny director it's
Thursday which means we are live today
for the daily Denny and I got a special
preview today for you of a tiny movie
that's opening this weekend I don't know
if you've heard of it Avengers infinity
war admittedly I am no Marvel expert and
I haven't seen the movie but I brought
in two people who have to help us break
down everything you need to know before
it hits theaters
please welcome to the daily Denny Ashe
crossing and John Boone team captain
that's right yeah man maybe like a Thor
okay you know what you got the captain
now you got the Chris Evans and while we
have seen it no spoilers here guys no
and don't look for spoilers I know right
it's good if you it's best if you just
go in unspoiled there are some big
surprises absolutely we see you guys on
the internet we see with the spoilers
like just enjoy your elbows like crazy
right exactly I haven't seen you guys so
I have a lot of questions for these guys
these guys I bet you do too so just
leave them in the comics comment section
I said comics get it like it's like it's
like the thing but uh okay guys leave
your comments and questions in the
comment section below we'll get into
this iPad but first you know as you guys
know Marvel and the Marvel Universe and
Avengers is shrouded in secrecy in fact
the cast even see it until the world
premiere this week here's what we do
know roughly more than sixty or so long
yeah 60 is Marvel characters are in this
movie in this epic epic crossover right
I mean that's better yeah I think that's
definitely fair to say I think it's like
sixty characters and you're talking
heroes the ones you know and love the
ones because it's a smaller number than
that can't afford them all you know be
an affordable but yes of course they're
all in this movie though which is super
epic it hasn't been done yet
and you know they're also facing off
Josh Brolin as Thanos which I am hearing
is touted as like one of the most
dangerous Marvel villains ever yeah yeah
he is he's big he's bad he's purple yeah
and everything that has happened in
previous Marvel films not everything but
a lot of the major battles especially in
the vendors these were all
coordinated by Thanos and he kind of
gets to a point where he's like alright
you guys aren't doing my dirty work for
you I'm gonna do this myself I'm gonna
get these Infinity stones and I'm gonna
he literally got to that point so it's
like 10 years worth or Marvel Marvel
films have been like leading up to this
one right yes so very very much
obviously ten years this is the 19th
Marvel movie a lot has happened before
the infinity war so catch us up Ashe
like where do you pick up I mean can you
give us a little rundown I think you
know years back you could kind of be
like okay like what is the casual fan
need to know or somebody that's never
seen a Marvel movie like what do they
need to know before this and that I
think for the first time like that
really doesn't exist with this movie
like you really have to have been
watching them a bit investing yeah and
that's not to say you can't get invested
in it now and go do a massive rewatch
but I don't think it's for the casual
fan at this point really great years in
the making my review is going up on ET
online and I admitted in it at this
point I don't have any gauge of how
these movies played as someone who
doesn't know the Canon because it's a
lot of heavy lifting if you don't know
what's happening
sure you can see it because there's like
fun superheroes in cool costumes
flashing lights and Chris Pratt but well
then riddle me this like for the casual
fan who maybe have seen a handful or a
few of the Marvel movies which one
should they watch now to catch up and
kind of know going into infinity war I
would say the main one is Captain
America Civil War that is like really
where we left off with the bulk of the
Avengers and then the movies kind of
after that you have Thor Spiderman
homecoming Doctor Strange and black
panther those are ones that definitely
add to the story a lot because I think I
think it pretty much picks up after Thor
Ragnarok so while they are released in a
certain order it's not necessarily the
chronological order but I would say
civil war and then the movies that take
place after that are pretty important
but civil war at the most so because
that's where we kind of and then if you
go before that I would say guardians one
is
what kind of first establishes the
mythology of Thanos that's kind of the
that's also the first time josh brolin
playtime right so you get to figure out
dibbles and dabbles of what his deal is
I also think that I'm so angry that's
more in this one you find out why he's
Guardians lends a lot to that yeah yeah
and then obviously the first Avengers
was when Loki was doing Thanos as
bidding and that's kind of really what
kicked to this all oh yeah so where do
we leave off with team caps so yeah
that's the thing if you've seen these
movies maybe once or twice back when
they're in theaters I think that's the
hardest thing to remember when you're
watching infinity Wars you'll be like
wait where was this person last like
that was kind of thing that was going
through my head so yeah as far as at the
end of civil war we have team cap kind
of losing getting locked up in the raft
which is like a maximum security prison
for enhanced people and enhanced heroes
and cap breaks them out at the end and
then we have that you know Hawkeye goes
home where's Hawkeye got ant-man he goes
home we've got Sam Wilson Falcon he
stays with cap and then girl Johansson
Black Widow stays with cap as well but
then and then Rhodey of course was
paralyzed
towards the end of Civil War because he
was shot down by vision who was trying
to shoot Falcon but Steve Rogers kind of
chooses Bucky over iron man and kind of
takes him up and is walking away with
him this really dramatic moment of iron
man shouting at him and saying you know
that shield does not belong to you that
belonged to my father he made it he made
it drops the shield and that was kind of
a moment that I had to remember being
like wait why doesn't cap have a shield
oh yeah because he dropped it cuz Iron
Man was dramatically screaming at him
and then we see in that mid-credits
scene I believe it's the mid-credits
scene in Civil War where Captain America
actually takes Bucky to Wakanda where he
kind of goes under and Shirley freezes
him and sure he's kind of kind of
working on him to see kind of what's
going on with him because he has all
those trigger memories from Hydra and
well conda's is a safe ground right for
all of the Avengers really right
supposedly I mean it was previously
unknowable right known and so now then
the Black Panther
it's technically open to the world
we you'll find out a little more of how
open okay okay yeah and then of course
you have you have Scarlet Witch envision
which this actually isn't revealed in
civil war was like a prelude comic that
happens leading up to infinity war that
they're together so and there they went
to Europe and they're starting a life
together we got a little case of em yeah
we saw them like kind of flirting and
cooking for each other or whatever but
and then so after Civil War you have
spider-man homecoming I'm kind of not
doing these in an exact order but
spider-man homecoming is kind of where
you see what happens with with Tony
Stark necks he is like leading the
Avengers and kind of mentoring and
figuring out who the new Avengers are
going to be and he's kind of taking
Peter Parker under his wing and towards
the end he says all right you can join
the Avengers and Peter Parker turns it
down because he thinks it's a test right
and it wasn't but what I loved about
that moment is it does reveal that him
and Pepper Potts Gwyneth Paltrow have
reconciled is back in the picture and
then guardians of galaxy vol 2 is
another one that kind of leads into
infinity war because you have Peter
quill meeting defeating the dad you know
the yondu sacrifice sorry for all these
Polish come on yeah they want to be
there opening weekend but where we kind
of leave off with them as they're just
flying through space mm-hmm but that is
like an important note to remember where
they were and then you have nebula who
was the villain kind of kind of crossed
over to the other side and and
reconciled with her sister Gamora and
you know they are both fans and she has
left to go kill thanos that was where we
left off with her hey you feeling Donny
oh you know I should be taking notes oh
you guys are watching yeah there will be
a quiz but I'm entertained yeah Wow
Marvel's fun guys Marvel's fun and then
you have Doctor Strange which was really
an origin story of dr. strange but it is
important because we you know we lost
all him actually input in thor ragnarok
where he's like kind of harnessing his
powers but much better at he's now oh
he's so great he's so great in his
little part in that but that's actually
a very I think very important re-watch
that you'll see but he is you know the
holder and the protector of the
automata which has you know is that one
of the okay so Stannis is gonna be going
for that yeah okay and then I mentioned
thor ragnarok you know we we end there
with thor kind of saving all the people
of Asgard and they're on their ship and
on their way to earth with Loki with
Heimdall play by idris elba with
Valkyrie and they have Bruce Banner the
hall the Hulk which he you know you
might forget he was he was not involved
in civil war you know he was he was over
in sac are being the the champion of
Sekar so he doesn't pop up I mean you
know he wasn't in sabor he wasn't there
so that's kind of where rather Hulk nor
Thor Thor yes that's kind of what they
were off doing so much of this movie
Infinity Ward the excitement has been
around like seeing the Avengers in the
Guardians meet up but you do forget how
long it's been since some of these
characters that have not seen each other
yeah yeah and then of course a lot of
people saw Black Panther right right
it's the most recent Marvel movie how
much of that does does that play into
infinity war like that world I would say
like the world of Wakanda is very
important you just have to see black
panther before this because this can't
be the first time you go to a condo this
can't be the first time you meet Sheree
and a koi yay yeah it's it just doesn't
not that it's bad by any means but it
doesn't quite do them justice go in
knowing them go in knowing that world
yeah it just makes it all the better I
mean yeah without spoiling really
anything there's one part in the movie
where you just hear the faintest drums
of Wakanda and my audience went crazy
there are a few of those moments for
sure and then there's there's a the mid
creditor post karna I always mix them up
and don't know which one but it kind of
reveals what happens to Bucky after he
was taken to what condo okay and he's
you know we can back up the way he's the
way well he's the white Walker I love
that that's a really good recap i if you
guys are joking
wow I'm sorry why once this live is over
but ash and Josh just took us through a
recap of all the Marvel movies you
should probably
watch before infinity war so thanks for
that you do get to they do kind of cover
a lot of this in the movie and they try
to make it cheeky and fun there are some
exposition dumps to catch you up but
yeah but the more you know the easier
yeah I think for me like the most
important thing to remember when I went
into it was just like just remembering
kind of where everybody was because
that's something where you're just like
oh yeah like you know at this point a
few years ago if you did miss it though
you can't go to et online.com to read
John Boone's article cuz he does give
you a nice little recap there yeah let's
talk about the villain a little bit more
mana I know ya knows I'm he's
scary-looking the big bad I mean it's
just is you know it's just the villain
that we've been building up to for so
long and he's finally and he looks so
much better now than he did at the end
of Avengers oh this just the CGI the CGI
at the end of Avengers he like turns
around and it's this huge grin and he
looks he looks good he looks really good
especially in close-up in this you can
like see Josh Brolin yeah yeah no
there's there are parts like you know
yeah I don't want to give too much away
but he it is just it's it works so well
I don't know and and part of having seen
all those past movies and knowing all
these characters is you know thanassis
connection to everyone because that has
been established a lot throughout he's
killed a lot of people that these people
know he's the father of two of them
right he's dealt with people's brothers
it's he's got his fingers and a lot of
things yeah the stakes are so high
payoff is when you watch this movie is
higher and like you mentioned it's been
building up building up building up to
this and there's only one person that
could go up against these many
superheroes right yeah it's this guy I
love that so I've been foggy who is the
head of Marvel Studios actually said
that they were what he kind of implied
was there was discussion about doing fan
OHS earlier and another Avengers of
doing him and a Guardians and there just
wasn't enough heroes right they didn't
have enough heroes to take him on so
there
finally getting to a point with these
billion of people in this movie yeah and
maybe have a chance
totally so the main plot though the
storyline there the through line I
should say is that Thanos isn't search
for these Infinity stones you have them
from information right yeah I won't say
before you get so it's really awesome to
see them in action
oh yeah yeah you get moments of seeing
what each one of them does you don't
happen to know yeah well yeah the the
directors the Russo brothers have said
they wanted to keep the plot of this
movie very simple kind of a heist movie
so that all these people and all these
characters can kind of just come around
it and so the main thrust of the movie
is Thanos in his minions who are pretty
dope going around and collecting these
six atones and the six stones are
there's the green stone which is the
time stone and that's what worked a
strange yes yeah okay yes and so that's
in the little eye the last we saw it
actually the last we saw he's just
wearing dr. strange they were like don't
wear I can't handle the responsibility
and then we seen in Thor and he's just
it's just as regular bling then there's
the purple one too which is the power
stone that was the one that played into
guardians one where they did the
dance-off all held hands things turn
purple yeah and that is with Nova Corps
who is Glenn closes little organization
in like the cops and Guardians yeah then
there's the reality stone which is the
red stone that's from Thor to the dark
world that's the one Whitter unfavorite
that's the one where Natalie Portman
finds it just like a floating red liquid
in a warehouse and just was like I'm
gonna touch it I have so many questions
about like the way that they decide to
protect these infinities cuz I feel like
I would go get them myself if I wanted
that one was question but at the end of
that movie they left it with the
collector who is Benicio Del Toro's
character with is like white eyebrows
and
eccentricity z' and then there's the
blue one that's the space stone that's
kind of been the one that's been kicking
around the most did the tesseract from
the original Captain America from the
original Avengers last we saw of that
was in Odin's vault in thor ragnarok and
maybe or maybe not Loki has it now he
spotted it and okay we won't say much
more okay
then lose spoiler free here okay two
more we got two more run home run um
there's the yellow one right mine stone
that's in vision vision I know that so
he essentially is a living infinity
stone which is not looking good for him
so protect him at all costs
there's no and then there's the soul
stone which is an orange stone which
there are a gajillion fan theories about
where it is ya know we don't know okay
nobody knows for the stole stone is okay
so the goal protect the stones keep them
away from Thanos yes okay love that all
right guys so obviously the stakes are
high in this one I think a big question
that a lot of people will have before
they watch it is what does the future
hold not just for the Avengers in the
film ball so for Marvel - where's this
going well we know the next three movies
and then the next three are a man and
the wasp in July
yeah then Captain Marvel next year with
his which is brie Larson and then
Avengers for which doesn't have a title
yet so we know there's gonna be another
event yes yeah I think I think my
question is like what is happening after
Avengers 4 like it back that is so like
yeah yeah well Ashley and I will have
much more speculation yeah what will
happen in Avengers 4 but after you see
of course well one thing is certain
though like this cast has been the last
decade in various films together and
they have clearly bonded in fact we were
on the set of infinity infinity world
with Chris Evans and Scarlett Johansson
where they talked about how they've
literally grown up together like a lot
of the characters excuse me the actors
are having kids now so he talked about
the bond and also what the future holds
for them and how excited they are for
future Avengers films take a look
great I mean it's so nice to kind of
watch the evolution just I mean
independent of the movies just the
friendships I'm watching them grow
involvements and we've known for a long
time become parents yeah
you know more if it's their adulthood is
really a beautiful thing because this
has been what nearly a decade this room
this process this franchise so you guys
really have become close become a family
in a way right yeah I'm excited for even
our the next infinity where this thing
really does go on forever but you know
we even get to it won't even be like a I
think more of an opportunity for as all
these pieces come together you know you
know we'll really have an opportunity to
work you know always kind of you guys
are pros I don't how many more of these
movies do they have in them that Chris
Evans beard really is the start anew oh
it's heavy twins really I love that all
right guys so I wouldn't get since you
both have seen the movie and in fact we
were actually getting some comments and
Edward from facebook says this movie is
going to be lit on so many levels would
you agree with that yeah later on a
level you're you're really not even
expecting yeah okay yeah I I think I was
going into it kind of being like I just
want to know what happens and that's the
attitude I went into it what like and it
is like it's very epic and like
unexpected and surprising and all these
emotions but I can't wait to see it
again from the perspective of knowing
what happens in life because really soak
it in like mind-blowing is like a
hyperbole but you do feel like your
brain like short-circuited by the all
right yeah and it's what it's like two
hours and 40 minutes did you feel like
that was long or did you feel like you
wanted more uh not anymore but it's
seeing around so much
brought the whole movie that like
there's always something happening yeah
you're in an action scene within the
first minutes of the movie and that does
not stop them okay yeah definitely and I
will sit like from a character
perspective which is like always my
favorite part of the movie it's this
movie has some of the best character
interactions in any Marvel movie it
makes so much time for them that's why
it's 2 hours and 40 minutes because they
give these characters room to just like
joke around with each other bicker with
each other and that is the best part of
the movie so the moments in between the
action are just as entertaining and as I
mean that's what I was worried about
that I was like well there's so many
characters there fighting fan oasw's
like how much time are they really gonna
have to interact and build a story and
there is time for that and I love that
yeah I want to get to Ashley's question
from YouTube she says not me
I know great name how awesome was the
movie on a scale 1 to 10 I have to see
it again
because right now I'm at like I'm at an
8 and I feel like I could be at a ton I
feel like I feel like in the middle you
might be like I'm like that yeah didn't
8 I after that ending I think I'm a
solid 10 yeah and I'm just amazed they
pulled this off forever I will be amazed
that this is a spectacle movie heavy on
the spectacle I love that and it is in
it is a feat oh there's a feat well a
lot of fans here are saying they're so
excited to see yeah I'm excited to see
it hottest Avenger sorry comment call
early we gotta answer this question real
quick for theater from Facebook who is
the hottest Avenger I think I could
probably chime in on this one Groot
Groot that's exactly know I gotta say
it's hands down between Thor Evans yeah
okay I would go okay we're gonna
actually screw the cella doesn't exist
oh my god you know we're gonna let you
guys figure that one out let us know in
the comments who you think is the
hottest Avenger okay I can be down with
that one for sure actually
I'm so excited are you guys gonna see it
tonight I want to know we're wrapping
things up guys thank you so much for
your time for your Avengers fixed you
guys make sure you head over to ET
online.com we have plenty of content
there including John's preview and
also we have full interviews with the
entire cast from various interviews et
has done over on our YouTube channel so
check those out as well um thank you
guys again for joy adventures of sanity
war and I'll be back tomorrow with a
brand new daily Denny are you guys see
ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]